♪ ♪
>> Tucker: OVER THE WEEKEND
JEFF BEZOS PERSONAL NEWSPAPER
WITH A GEORGIA POLITICIAN CALLED
STACY’S STOMACH STACEY ABRAMS.
THAT IS NOT SURPRISING SHE HAS A
WELL-KNOWN LEFT DEMOCRATS AND
"THE WASHINGTON POST" EXIST FOR
PEOPLE LIKE THAT FOR DECADES AND
OFTEN HAVE.
BUT EVEN BY THE USUAL STANDARD
OF OVER-THE-TOP SLOBBERING
HACKERY, THIS PIECE THAT EXISTS
IN ITS OWN CATEGORY.
BY THE END OF THE NEARLY 6,000
WORDS OF UNMITIGATED PRAISE, YOU
BEGIN TO WONDER WHY NO ONE HAS
RELIGION BASED ON STACEY ABRAMS
PEER OF THE WORLD’S ABRAHAM MAKE
FAITH.
ACCORDING TO
"THE WASHINGTON POST," ABRAMS IS
A LOT MORE THAN A FORMER STATE
ELECTED OFFICIAL THAT GOES ON
TELEVISION CABLE A LOT.
SHE IS A SPIRITUAL THINKER.
INDEED SHE IS QUITE POSSIBLE THE
AUTHOR OF REDEMPTION.
LISTEN TO HOW THE THOROUGHLY
SMITTEN ENCOUNTER BETWEEN STACEY
ABRAMS AND DEVOTED ACCOLADES.
KEEP IN MIND AS YOU HEAR THIS,
WE ARE NOT MAKING ANY OF IT UP.
THIS VERBATIM "PANDEMONIUM AS
SHE WALKS TO THE FAR LEFT OF THE
STAGE LIKE A RUNWAY SUPERMODEL,
STOPS ON A DIME, POSES, TILTS
HER HEAD SLIGHTLY AND SMILES.
CAMERA FLASHES, EXPLODES AND
ABRAMS WITH HER INNER ACTRESS
AND BOTH ENJOYING THE MOMENT IN
GETTING THROUGH IT TO GET TO THE
CONVERSATION.
SO SHE’S LIKE A SUPERMODEL BUT
SHE IS ALSO A SUPERHERO.
IN FACT THE PIECE WAS ENTITLED
"THE POWER OF STACEY ABRAMS."
IN A COMFORTING PHOTO A SUPERMAN
CAPE TRAILING BEHIND HER.
JUST IN CASE YOU MISSED THE
POINT OF THE PIECE, THIS WOMAN
WILL SAVE THE WORLD.
AND "THE WASHINGTON POST" THINKS
THAT’S POSSIBLE.
THE STORY WAS DESIGNED COME OF
COURSE TO PUSH JOE BIDEN TO PICK
STACEY ABRAMS AS THE RUNNING
MATE.
NO ONE WHO KNOWS JOE BIDEN OR
WATCHES HIM CAREFULLY THINKS HE
CAN LEAD THIS COUNTRY AND HIS
CONDITION OR SURVEY FULL TERM IN
A CEREMONIAL AS PRESIDENT BY
ANYONE AS VICE PRESIDENT UNDER
JOE BIDEN WOULD IN FACT BE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
ALL OF WHICH RAISES THE OBVIOUS
QUESTION, WHO EXACTLY IS THIS
STACEY ABRAMS THAT WE ARE
RELENTLESSLY PROMOTING?
WHAT EXAMPLE DOES SHE DO FOR A
LIVING?
PROBABLY THE FIRST QUESTION BUT
AS IT TURNS OUT, NOT MUCH.
SUPPOSEDLY, ABRAMS RUNS
POLITICAL ACTION COMMITTEE PAID
FOR BY MIKE BLOOMBERG AND SHE
ALSO SERVES ON A FEW BOARDS.
ALL IN ALL, IT IS NOT A HEAVY
LIFT ALL BOYS.
HER ACTUAL LOCATION IS BEING
PROFESSIONALLY AGREED.
SHE SERVED IN THE GEORGIA STATE
HOUSE, A REAL JOB AND THE
HIGHEST OFFICE SHE HAS HUDDLED
IN THE GEORGIA STATE HOUSE.
WHILE SHE WAS THERE, SHE
ACCOMPLISHED VIRTUALLY NOTHING.
WE CHECKED.
2016 SHE DID GET THE BILL TO
ORDER THE POLICE TO SEIZE BY
FORCE AND ALL SO-CALLED ASSAULT
WEAPONS IN THE STATE.
THE SAME WOULD MAKE A FELONY
POSSESSION WITH A HIGH-CAPACITY
MAGAZINE.
AND POLICE WOULD HAVE BEEN
OBLIGED TO SEE THOSE BY FORCE.
AND THAT WAS ABOUT IT.
WHY DO WE KNOW HER NAME, BECAUSE
IN 2018, STACEY ABRAMS LOST THE
GEORGIA GOVERNOR’S RACE AND A
POSTELECTION SHE CAME UP SHORT
BY 55,000 VOTES, HALF A PERCENT
AND A TURNOUT IN DECADES AND
LESS BY 55,000 VOTES.
AND HOW DID ABRAMS RESPOND?
SHE DECLARED HERSELF GOVERNOR
ANYWAY AND DENOUNCED ANYONE WHO
DISAGREED WITH THAT AS A RACIST.
, AS THEY MIGHT HAVE DONE, AND
FELLOW DEMOCRATS PLAYED ALONG
WITH THE FANTASY.
>> WITHOUT VOTER SUPPRESSION,
STACEY ABRAMS WOULD BE THE
GOVERNOR OF GEORGIA.
>> IF THIS COUNTRY WASN’T
RACIST, STACEY ABRAMS WOULD BE
GOVERNOR.
>> IT WAS THE VOTER SUPPRESSION
PARTICULARLY IF THE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN COMMUNITY THAT
PREVENTED US FROM HAVING A
GOVERNOR, STACEY ABRAMS RIGHT
NOW.
>> STACEY ABRAMS OUT TO BE THE
GOVERNOR OF GEORGIA.
FRIENDS, RACIALLY MOTIVATED
SUPPRESSION IS PERMITTED.
WE CANNOT TRULY SAY WE LIVE IN A
DEMOCRACY.
>> THIS COUNTRY WAS NOT RACIST.
STACEY ABRAMS WOULD BE GOVERNOR.
BY THE WAY AS A FACTUAL MATTER,
THERE IS LITERALLY ZERO EVIDENCE
TO SUPPORT THAT IS TRUE OR EVEN
SORT OF TRUE, IT DOESN’T MATTER,
THE FACT THAT STACEY ABRAMS
ISN’T THE GOVERNOR OF GEORGIA,
DESPITE LOSING A FAIR ELECTION
WITH THE HIGHEST VOTER TURNOUT
IN DECADES CAN ONLY BE RACISM.
THAT IS STACEY ABRAMS POSITION.
IN FACT, SHE IS MAKING THE SAME
CASE TO GET HERSELF SELECTED AS
THE VICE PRESIDENTIAL NOMINEE.
IF JOE BIDEN DOESN’T CHOOSE
STACEY ABRAMS, HE’S RACIST.
SPEAK WHO DO MAKE >> DO YOU
THINK NOT CHOOSING A WOMAN OF
COLOR COME A BLACK WOMAN
ACTUALLY IS A SLAP IN THE FACE
TO THE BLACK FEMALE VOTERS?
>> I WOULD SHARE YOUR CONCERN OF
NOT PICKING A WOMAN OF COLOR BUT
BE STOMACH BECAUSE BLACK WOMEN
ARE THE STRONGEST PART OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
WE NEED TO REFLECT THE DIVERSITY
OF AMERICA.
>> Tucker: YEAH, YOU NEED TO
PICK STACEY ABRAMS, THAT IS WHAT
YOU NEED MR. RACIST GUY.
SAY WHAT YOU WILL ABOUT STACEY
ABRAMS, THERE IS NO MISTAKING
HER MOTIVES ARMING.
AND GIVE HER WHAT SHE WANTS OR
SHE WILL CALL YOU RACIST.
IT IS SIMPLE, AND IDENTITY
POLITICS AND OF COURSE, ABRAMS’
FOR THAT TOO PROUDLY.
>> I BELIEVE AND IDENTITY
POLITICS.
IDENTITY POLITICS ARE THE ONLY
POLITICS THAT WIN.
AND DID ABRAMS LEARN THAT
CYNICAL LITTLE SLOGAN?
YALE LAW SCHOOL LIKE SO MANY
POLITICAL FIGURES BEFORE SHE
WENT.
JOE BIDEN FALL FOR THIS?
PROBABLY, WE CAN CONFUSED AND
DESPERATE TO MAKE THE END GROUP,
THE COOL KIDS.
WHAT SHOULD THE REST OF US FALL